Green: Hi.
Welcome.
I'm Brad Green.
I'm the manager
of Accessibility Engineering
at Google and...
Rosenthal:
And I'm Erin Rosenthal,
the Product Manager
for Accessibility.
Green: Fantastic.
So we're gonna talk
a little bit about
what accessibility means
in products
and how we can use features
that are built in
to the platforms
that Google offers.
Erin, can you go
to the next slide?
Okay. So just a couple
of questions.
How many of you
have some experience
with accessibility technology
already?
Okay. A little more than half.
That's fantastic.
How many of you are actually
responsible for building
accessibility
into your products?
A couple of us.
Okay, keep your hands up.
How many of you know the
current gaps in your products
and know how to fix them?
Okay. Fair number. Okay.
So that's what we're here
to talk about.
We're gonna, first of all,
talk a little bit about
some--
what users expect
or are looking for
in accessible products.
And I'll just make a point
that we're gonna go into
some particular use cases
but the range of accessibility
is wide.
There are a lot of
different use cases,
ways that we'd like to make
our applications accessible.
What we're gonna talk about
forms a framework
for many different modes
of accessibility, um,
that users can take advantage of
in your apps.
We're gonna talk about
how you build accessibility
specifically in our products
Chrome and Android.
And then we're gonna show you
what tools we have
to both build and test
these applications.
We're gonna follow with
some cool demos.
We're gonna show you what we
think are inspirational
applications that show off
some of the best features
in accessibility.
Rosenthal: So you're
probably asking yourself--
granted, most of you
seem to know
a lot about accessibility
already--
but a lot of people ask,
"Why should I care?
Why should I make
my product accessible?"
Well, there's a number
of reasons.
Number one is actually
it makes financial sense
for your company.
The government and education
tend to have requirements
for accessibility in the
products that they purchase,
and they're very large
contracts,
very large groups that you can
sell your products into.
So it's really important
to make sure
that your products
are accessible
so that you can compete
in that marketplace
and get them as large-paying
customers, right?
The main reason
that government and education
want products
to be accessible
are so that students
can continue to learn
and learn alongside
sighted students
and hearing students
in school
and so that as people grow
and move into the workplace
that they can continue to work
alongside their peers
in companies like ours,
right?
Also, I know for me,
it always helps me
when I work on something
that enables people
to do something
they weren't able
to do before.
That feels great,
and I like working on
accessibility because of that,
that it's really--it's a good
feel-good thing, right?
You know, so you can see that
people weren't able to do this,
and now they can.
Wonderful.
Also, there's a lot of
additional technology benefit
to making your products
accessible.
A lot of underlying technologies
that you put into your products
will benefit you
in other ways.
So for example,
with Android,
when we were making it
accessible,
we added a text to speech
engine.
Well, later that came in handy
as a way to do
driving directions
in the maps application.
We already had
the text engine there,
so it could just
rely on it there.
Green: That's right, Erin.
As a matter of fact,
there's a lot of other places
where accessibility
is kind of like a moon mission.
The technologies we develop
that are for helping people
access the platform
are usable to everybody.
Matter of fact,
they help all of your users.
For example,
in keyboard access,
we as developers, we rely
heavily on keyboard shortcuts.
Adding keyboard access
to your applications
may be the number one thing
for web apps
that you can do
to make it more accessible.
Not just for folks who might
not be able to use a mouse,
but for everybody.
Like I want a hot key
for almost every one
of the special--
every one of the use cases
that I have in an application.
There are some technologies
like text to speech
and speech recognition
that were once thought of
as exotic interface elements--
are now becoming commonplace.
You notice on Android
I can add a speech
recognition element, um...
to take input.
Also on many devices,
we have the ability
to give vibrational feedback,
what we call haptics.
And video game developers
found out
if they made
the controller vibrate
when different events happen
in the UI,
it becomes a much more
real experience.
The same is true
for my applications
when I can give some input
to the user that's not--
doesn't need to be overt.
I can make the device vibrate
and make it seem like
a real part of my world.
When I caption video streams,
it not only opens up the video
to folks who can't hear,
it allows me to do
really interesting things--
like you can run the captions
through a service
like Google Translate,
and all of a sudden,
all of the people
who aren't native speakers
can now access
the video content.
Customizable UIs,
as one example--
in Gmail, I can set my theme
and be able to set...
theme elements, backgrounds,
contrast, colors
might be kind of a nice thing,
personalization--
adding bling
to my environment--
might be actually
also required for some folks
who need different contrast,
different colors,
different magnification
in my application.
Testability, finally.
Turns out that if I'm building
an automated test,
it has a lot of the same needs
that, say, a blind user needs.
Like my automated test
can't use the mouse
and usually
can't read the screen,
and so these
accessibility features
form a very stable API
for me to build
automated tests against.
Let's go next.
Rosenthal: So let's talk
a little bit about the users,
people who use
accessible technology.
It's really important
for you to understand them
and how they interact
with your products,
just like all your other
users, right?
So the main thing
to keep in mind
are the input and output
technologies that they use
and making sure that you have
multiple redundant ways
of interacting
with your applications--
basically not relying
on a mouse,
not relying on rollovers
to be able to get
to your content.
So main ones to keep in mind
are for input using
keyboard and voice and touch,
and then some special
purpose displays
like this Braille display
that we have pictured here
where you can do corded input.
And then also for feedback--
feedback's really vital
so that your user knows
where they are on the screen
and what
they're interacting with
at all points in time, right?
So you should
make sure to have, again,
redundant feedback as well.
So not only have speech
but other audio cues
for when tasks complete or other
notifications are happening,
and also vibration feedback,
so that you get
that sense of reality
when you're using the product.
Plus, keep in mind other things
like the Braille display
that we have here
as another input--
or output device,
in this case.
Green: Okay. So we've got
a list of a couple things,
some sort of rules of thumb
for making accessible
applications...
how to think about
what sort of features
I need to pay attention to
as a developer.
First of all,
I kind of mentioned this.
Make sure
that all of my use cases
can actually be completed
without using a pointing device.
How do I do this?
Well, I unplug my mouse,
and I try and use
the application.
Usually, this means
that I'll have implemented
keyboard shortcuts
that I make sure that the--
if it's a web app,
that the tab order makes sense
and that I can actually
focus on
every element on the screen.
I also want to make sure
that I am managing focus well
inside my application.
For example,
if I'm using HTML
to simulate a modal dialog,
I wanna make sure that
I'm actually trapping events
so that if the user's trying
to tab through the elements
that they can't actually
reach the elements
that are behind my, uh,
my floating dialog box.
If you want more information
on this,
we've got a session tomorrow
which does a deep dive
on building accessible
HTML applications.
Depending on whether I'm on
Android or on the web,
there are several
declarative ways
that I can tell
assistive technologies
how to interact
with my application--
in the markup in the XML
for my Android application
or in the HTML
for my web-based application.
We'll go into a little bit
of this,
uh, and we have talks here
at I/O that go
much more into depth
on both of these.
And then lastly,
for me as a developer,
if I'm building
custom controls--
things that aren't part
of the standard widget set--
either on Android
or if I'm, you know,
putting a bunch of DIVs together
to look like
some kind of crazy new control
in HTML,
I'm gonna have to do a little
bit of extra work
to add accessibility
support there.
And finally,
uh, I just need to test it.
Um, it's--it's--
Uh, it's certainly disappointing
if I make--
put a lot of--
put some work into
making my application
to be accessible
and then find out that
maybe my login screen
is not accessible.
So I want to make sure
that I test
all the flows with the--
uh, assistive technologies
that I'm targeting.
Rosenthal: So what we're really
talking about here
are creating these
empowering products
that enable independence.
These are products that work
out of the box,
are easy to use,
that someone can set up
on their self--
by themselves,
and that are really easy
to learn and, um,
provide that good feedback
so that they
can get familiar
with the environment.
Um, this is such
a liberating feeling,
being able to do this
all on your own,
and it's really the right
thing to do.
Um, also, as Brad said,
keep in mind
to test your entire product
and not just think of,
like, the main part
of your interface,
but that from login
through documentation
and even your help center,
that all of that
is also accessible.
Green: Okay, I want to take
a little bit of a closer look
at building web applications
and what makes those accessible.
So if we get
in the way-back machine
and think back to the '90s
when the web was simple,
uh, how many of you
used Mosaic?
Oh, a bunch of us are old.
Okay, good.
Um, accessibility
back then, uh,
was a simple problem.
Um, usually app--
uh, you know,
web pages looked like this.
It was a bunch of text
and links
and maybe some images.
And accessibility meant adding
alt tags to images.
Matter of fact,
lot of us used alt tags
when my modem was too slow.
I'd turn images off and I'd just
read what the alt tags said.
But the world has changed.
Now even our most
simple applications
like Google Search have become
very rich and interactive,
so that as I'm typing,
Google Search updates
my complete set
of search results.
So we need to think differently
about how we're providing
accessibility
to these interactive,
dynamically-updating
applications.
They've gotten even more complex
and interesting
with apps like Google Gmail
and Google Calendar.
Uh, and, uh, like,
you name it.
There's so many apps out there
who are--
who have even richer interfaces.
So, as I mentioned,
one of the first things
we want to do is make sure
that I can access
all of the workflows in my
application via the keyboard.
Gmail, for example,
has a great set
of keyboard shortcuts
that give me access
to some of the most
common actions.
Uh, some of the other actions
I'll need to be able
to complete via other
keyboard focusing,
uh, by tabbing through
the application
and activating
through the keyboard.
I also talked a little bit
about that there
is specific markup that
I can add to my HTML page.
In, uh--
In the web,
there is a standard
called ARIA.
And ARIA gives me the ability
to tell assistive technologies
like screen readers
and Braille devices
how to interact with my UI.
So in my toolbar example
I have here,
I've, uh, marked it up
so that my images,
which are what a, uh--
someone who's using the mouse
would interact with--
so that if I'm using
a screen reader,
I can know that that "b"
up there is not
just an image,
but it should be interacted
with as a button,
so that a screen reader
can announce
that this is a button.
Matter of fact,
it has a label
that's specified
by my alt text there
that this will turn the text
that I have selected bold.
All right.
So, specifically,
what is Google doing to help?
Uh, I have a couple
announcements today.
I'm very excited to talk
about three things.
First, in Chrome, uh,
yesterday, we just blogged
that we are adding support
for some of the major
screen readers on Windows
with JAWS and NVDA on Mac
with voiceover
and, uh, uh,
and several others.
On ChromeOS,
you can't actually install
other software except
via extensions.
And so we're making available
a screen reader we call
ChromeVox.
And we're making it available
to you developers early
through a download,
so you cannot only use it
via ChromeOS,
but you can actually install it
in any version of Chrome
and use it on Windows
or Mac or Linux so that you
can see what it's like
to interact with your
application
using a screen reader.
We'll take a look at this
a little bit closer
later with a demo.
And then lastly,
uh,
we know a lot of you
photon-dependent users--
'cause you use the screen--
uh, like to see
what things look like.
So we've built an application
called ChromeShades.
And what ChromeShades does
is it shows you
what your application looks like
to a screen reader
and it allows you
to explore your application
visually but in the
sort of linear fashion
that a screen reader would
interact with your application.
We'll take a little
look at that,
and if you want a deeper dive,
please come see us
in the developer sandbox.
Okay, so, uh,
what does ChromeVox do for me?
Um, for those of you
who aren't familiar
with a screen reader, it does
a lot of the same things.
Uh, provides foken--
spoken feedback
as I navigate
through the application.
It uses ARIA,
which we just looked at,
and other accessibility
standards.
And it helps me work with
dynamic web applications
that we're now seeing,
uh,
by giving me,
uh, dynamic updates.
It tells me when things change
on the web page.
So there are some cases where
I want information spoken to me
and there are some cases
where I don't want,
uh, kind of the intrusive voice
to come up,
but I want maybe just some
audio indicator.
We call these things
"earcons."
Uh, little sounds
that tell me
when something has happened.
For example, when a
web page has finished loading
and is ready for me
to interact with it,
we'll play a sound rather than
announcing it with speech.
One thing we're doing
differently with ChromeVox,
uh, than we're doing
other places--
So we looked at ARIA.
ARIA is a declarative way
for me to specify
how screen readers can interact
with my app.
Now, declarative is great.
It's very easy.
It's very, uh--
It's not prone to bugs.
But it doesn't always work
for all cases
in a dynamic application.
So we're giving you
the developer
a, uh, imperative way
to tell it what to do
through something we call
VoxScript.
VoxScripts are, uh,
just JavaScript
written against
a very simple API
that lets you tell the
screen reader what to do.
Let's take a look
at what it lets us do.
Couple simple things.
Uh, number one, I can
position the screen reader--
I can tell it,
"Start reading from this point."
So for example,
if I've got a--
like, a toolbar
that goes across the top
that isn't something that
I always want to interact with,
maybe I'll start
the user reading
below the toolbar.
I can position it
by passing it the DOMNode
that I want it
to start speaking from.
I can also just have
it speak some text
by calling the speak command.
And then lastly,
we can have it play
one of our earcon audio
indicators.
So a couple fun things
to play with.
So VoxScript bridges
some of the gaps
we have in our
declarative ARIA
and gives us ways to--
to have more direct control.
All right, so I'm gonna
invite Charles Chen
up to the stage,
and he's gonna give us a demo
of ChromeVox right now.
We'll get to see
what it looks like.
Rosenthal: Switching over.
Green: Oh, okay,
actually,
while Charles
is setting that up,
I might--
Does anyone have a question
I can answer right now?
Please come to the mic.
man: ChromeVox looks
very interesting.
I was wondering if,
uh, any--
if, uh, the GWT team has
actually taken a look at this
so that we may be able
to work with that
with widgets that we build
in GWT?
Green: That's a great question.
Now, so the UI that you saw
we have is, uh--
The API is via JavaScript.
You can of course call any
of those from JavaScript.
But it's an interesting
question.
Like, what could
we automatically
enable from GWT?
But come talk to us later.
Let's discuss further.
Okay, one more question maybe
and then we'll go to Charles.
man: I'm from the GWT team.
Green: Oh, great.
man: And, uh, we don't have
anything in progress on that,
but we'd love to talk
to you about it.
Green: Fantastic.
Okay, good.
Hey, maybe the three of us
could get together.
All right, let's switch
to Charles,
who's gonna give us
a demo of ChromeVox.
Chen: Thank you, Brad.
So, uh, if we can switch--
All right, cool.
We've switched.
So, uh, Erin earlier
was talking about
how important it is to have
out of the box accessibility.
And we have this with ChromeVox
on ChromeOS.
So right now you see
the login screen.
If I press "control, alt, Z,"
I can enable ChromeVox.
computer: Accessibility
turned off.
Chen: It said "turned off"
because it was on before.
So let me go re-enable it
right now.
computer: Accessibility
turned on.
Chen: Okay, so now accessibility
is turned on.
I can start using it.
I'm gonna log into my account
and then
I'm gonna show you just how easy
it is to do a Google search.
computer: A-a-a-a-a-a-ast--
asterisk.
Chen: And notice it's saying
"asterisk."
It's not blurting out my
password, so.
computer: Signing in.
Chen: Tells me "signing in."
Okay.
[electronic tone]
computer: New tab.
Chen: Now you heard it
make that noise
and it said, "new tab."
So that noise is an earcon.
It's telling me that
the page is loaded,
it's ready for me
to interact with it,
and it told me the title.
In this case, it's "new tab."
So let me just do a search.
So, uh, now this is ChromeOS.
It's just like Chrome
the browser,
so if you go
into the URL bar,
you can type a query and it will
just do a search right there.
So let me do that.
I'm gonna press "control, L"
to jump
right into the URL bar,
and I'm just gonna type,
and let's see what happens.
computer: Location, text box.
We--a--
Unselected.
[electronic tone]
www.weather, Google search.
Chen: Okay, so it did
a Google search for weather.
Now this is Google Instant
search.
So Instant search,
by default,
draws a little arrow next
to the current result
that the user is looking at,
and the user
can use the arrow keys
up and down
to move through
the search results.
So we looked at that
and we said,
"This is a wonderful
keyboard-driven interface."
Like Brad was talking about
having good keyboard
accessibility.
And so can we take advantage
of that
and leverage it and
use some VoxScript to make it
work even better
and make it just speak
what the user's currently
interested in?
So rather than having
something complex
where the user
has to look at the title,
look at a snippet,
and then go back to the title
to activate something,
could we make it
as simple as just pressing
"down arrow,"
hearing it, and then just
pressing "enter"
to go to the page?
So here's the results.
I'm going to press "down arrow"
and "up arrow" a couple times
to show how it works.
computer: Weather current
conditions and forecast
for the San Francisco Bay.
May--National and local
weather forecast.
Hurricane, radar and--
San Francisco weather forecast
and conditions.
May 10--National
and local weath--
Weather current conditions
and foreca--
Weather for San Francisco.
C, 62 degrees Fahrenheit,
vertical bar, degree, Celsius,
Tue, Wed, Thu, Fri,
sunny, partially clou--
Chen: Okay.
And also very important
right there,
I pressed "control"
to make it stop speaking.
So, you know,
speech is silver,
silence is golden, right?
So, um, as you can see,
it's very easy
to do a Google search,
very easy to get your results.
You'll also notice
that the text got larger.
That's because we applied
the CSS style sheet.
So for low-vision users,
you get not just the audio,
but you also get the visual
of it getting larger.
And so with that,
you know,
that's a really intro--
good intro to how we can
do something that's complex
with Google search.
But let's look at something
that's even more complex.
Let's look at Gmail,
right?
So Gmail tries to replicate
a desktop email client
experience
in the browser on the web
with just HTML and JavaScript.
So how can we make that
accessible?
Can we make that fast?
Can we make that efficient?
Right?
And the answer is yes.
Yes, we can.
So, um, again,
we're going to see how
we take advantage of existing
keyboard shortcuts
and we make things just work.
So let me load up my Gmail here.
[electronic tone]
computer: W-w-g-m-a-i-l.
Mail.
C-o-m.
Degrees Celsius.
[electronic tone]
Chen: Okay, so it's loading.
[electronic tones]
Okay.
computer: Mail inbox.
309.
C-l-c-i-s-l-3-3-g at mail.com.
Chen: So as you can see,
it told me the title
and it told me
how many messages I had.
And so with Gmail,
if you have keyboard shortcuts,
you can just use the "j" and "k"
keys to move
through the different threads
of emails.
You can press "enter"
to open an email.
And after you've opened
an email thread,
you can press any key...
computer: Not selected.
Chen: To go through the, uh--
to go through the messages
inside the thread.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and do that right now.
computer: Unread.
Thomas, left square, bracket,
right square, bracket,
Windows registry installation.
Unread.
Through left square--
Left square, brack--
Unread.
Has a blue line.
Chen: Okay, so I'm gonna
go ahead and open this thread.
I'm gonna press "enter."
[electronic tone]
computer: Not selected.
Chen: Okay, so now it's telling
me nothing is selected.
I can go ahead and read through
the messages with "N" and "P."
[computer speaking rapidly]
computer: Show details.
Monday, May 9, 2011,
at 10:52 P.M.
I am developing
an Android application
for encryption decryption
of messages.
I need some hash algorithm
to generate--
[computer speaking rapidly]
Show details.
Monday, May 9.
[computer speaking rapidly]
Show details.
Monday, May 9, 2011,
at 11:59 P.M.
developer.android.com/reference/
java/security/spec/mgf--
Chen: Okay, so that--
[Rosenthal laughs]
See, now that was actually
a very interesting URL.
So I wanted to explore
that more
and as, um, as Brad and Erin
mentioned earlier,
with VoxScript you can
sync the screen reader
to your current position.
So now I'm on this message.
Let's say I wanted
to read that in more detail,
because that was just way
too fast, right?
So I can use the standard
ChromeVox commands
to read through.
So on ChromeOS,
this is "search" and "shift."
And if you're running this
as just an extension
in your Chrome browser,
then it's "control" and "alt."
So I'm going to, uh,
read through this message.
[computer speaking rapidly]
computer:
developer.android.com--
developer.android.--
Sentence.
[computer speaking rapidly
and indistinctly]
S-h-a 256.
Chen: So as you can see,
I can now navigate through it
in a very fine-grained way
and go through the message
a word at a time,
sentence at a time,
at any level I would like.
And so with that,
I would like
to hand it back to Brad.
Green: Great.
Erin.
Rosenthal: I think that's
actually me.
computer: Not selected.
Chen: Yeah.
So can we switch back?
Rosenthal: Yes.
Green: Thanks, Charles.
That's awesome.
Rosenthal: Yeah, thank you
so much, Charles.
Chen: You want to ask
questions or should I?
Rosenthal: Um,
so as you can see,
with ChromeVox
you're able to make, like,
a desktop-like experience
through your web application
on ChromeOS, right?
Um, ChromeVox
and VoxScripts give you
this unprecedented level
of control
to make sure that you have this
tight integration that you want
with the screen reader
so that you can provide
this seamless user experience
that your users
have grown to expect
in their desktop applications.
There's also one more technology
that Brad had mentioned
that we wanted to show you
a quick screenshot of
and that's ChromeShades.
So, um, this is
an extension available
on our website,
and it allows you to visualize
what your website
or application looks like
to someone using
a screen reader.
Um, as Brad says,
for people who are
photon-dependent.
Um, so what it does is
flatten your page
and show it in the link order
that the person
who would be navigating
with the screen reader,
how they would come to it
and how they would end up
navigating it.
So in this case,
you see that the buttons
that are across the top
of the page
end up being linearized
at the beginning
of the ChromeShades version
of the page,
and the "any" button that's
unlabeled in the interface
is showing up as these green,
rounded wraps.
So clearly we have
some work to do here.
It's a good thing
we have this tool.
So let's talk
a little bit about
accessibility in Android.
Mobile platforms are fantastic
platforms for accessibility.
There are so many sensors
built in
that there is this inherent
accessibility
that's already there.
These devices are designed
for use
when being distracted,
when your eyes are elsewhere.
So that helps people who need
accessible interfaces as well.
Plus, um,
Android in particular
is an open and customizable
platform, right?
So you can choose the device
that works for you.
You can get one with a keyboard
if you want it.
Plus, also, today,
when we were in the keynote,
we announced the, uh,
Android developer platform,
right?
So you can make, uh,
third-party extensions.
So with that,
you could make something
that really is specific
to the disabled users
in your community.
So as we said, there's all
these sensors built in.
So think of them as all these
eyes and ears
that you can use to make
location aware,
context aware, and extremely
powerful applications.
Um, the more aware your
application is,
the less that your users need
to interact with it.
While that might sound like
something you don't want--
you want them to interact--
you don't want them
to have to get stuck inputting
all this tedious details,
all this data, right?
If you can tell them
their location for them
instead of them having
to figure out--
Like, right now,
do you know where you are
if you had to put
in your location?
No, you'd have a hard time,
right?
So you really would prefer
your phone
to be able to set that for you,
right?
So we've written a couple
applications
that demonstrate this
technology.
Um, both of them,
I think,
we're demoing over
in our sandbox, by the way,
if you want to check
'em out yourself.
Um, this first one is an app
called Walky Talky.
Uh, this is a interface
to the maps app
that gives you the ability to
set a start and end point
and then it'll give you
walking directions
for the route that you're on.
Um, then as you're walking
along your route,
it'll read off whatever
intersection you're at.
Um, I know for me this would
be incredibly useful
if I'm just kind of walking
in an unfamiliar area.
I can only imagine how valuable
it would be if I'm blind
and would have a difficult time
seeing exactly where I am.
So this application helps build
that confidence
in your environment
in knowing where you are
as you're--and that you're
on the right direction.
Um, also there's this
application called
Intersection Explorer.
If you went to the Android talk
earlier,
you saw a demo of it
and as Ramen explained,
he wrote this, um,
after getting dropped off
on the wrong corner one day
on the way home.
This app, uh,
helps you to understand
what intersections
or what streets are nearby.
So, like, if you're traveling
and want to get to know
an area before you
get there and know
what the general streets are,
you can, um, open up this app,
set yourself
at an intersection,
and then drag your finger
in a circle,
uh, around the intersection
that you're at.
Um, it will
then vibrate subtly
when you get to a street
and read off the street name
and the direction.
So, like, in this case,
if I did a circle,
um, from the top,
it would first say--
it would vibrate a little
and say, "Howard Street,
Northeast."
And, um,
that would help me know
what streets meet up
where I am.
Green: All right, fantastic.
So there's several services
that are parallel
to what we're doing on ChromeOS
and Chrome for Android
and we've had these in place
actually for much longer.
There's an accessibility
framework
that's built up
of a number of APIs.
We'll talk about
a few of them.
And there are services
which users can enable
as part of their preferences.
So on any Android device,
you can pull it out right now.
Go to preferences,
accessibility,
and you get to enable things
like TalkBack,
which is our screen reader.
Allows the UI to be announced
and allows you to navigate
by focusing on elements.
We have KickBack,
which is the haptic feedback,
which gives me more of a
realistic, real-world experience
when I'm interacting with
the different elements.
Um, and then SoundBack,
which plays the equivalent
of what we called earcons--
um, audio non-spoken events
that tell me when something's
happened in my application.
Again, Erin kind of
mentioned it,
but this is--It's a very
open platform.
It's all open source.
Um, but we've made
it particularly
easy to integrate along
many axes.
One example is that
we ship a voice
with the device for doing
text to speech.
And, uh, it's perfectly good
and functional,
but if you want a slightly
sexier, sassier voice,
one that happen--works
in a different language,
um, or, you know,
one that's just more
to your preference,
you can go
to the marketplace
and you can download one of many
different ones
that are available there,
uh,
written by some of our
application partners.
Okay, so, uh,
these devices--
We've talked a little bit about
what we have to do.
More specifically,
if I'm an application developer,
to make my application
accessible on Android,
uh, the first thing--
If I just use
the standard controls,
out of the box, they come
with accessibility baked in.
If I label those controls
by setting their content
description appropriately,
it will automatically know how
to speak the elements
when we focus on them.
Now, users are going to be
focusing on these in maybe
a couple different ways.
One is if my device has
a roller ball or a D-pad--
that sort of directional pad you
see down there on the screen--
it allows me to set focus
on different elements in my UI.
The ones that come out
of the box
automatically know how
to be focused.
If I'm building my own custom
views however,
I need to make sure that all
of these controls
are both reachable and
respond to the right events,
that they could be focused,
and that they will raise
the appropriate accessibility
events.
There's some simple APIs.
We'll show you a link
where to go to
to look at that
at the end of the talk,
um, and please come to our
developer sandbox
and we'd love to show you
more about that.
Rosenthal: So, um,
with that, we want to--
You remember how earlier
we mentioned
we were gonna have demos?
We're gonna bring up
Steve Jacobs
to show us some demos
of some applications
that he's written for Android
that are highly accessible.
Green: And while he's getting
set up,
uh, we could take
another question
if somebody has one about
what we've just talked about.
Rosenthal: Let me switch over.
Green: Anyone?
Jacobs: Well, if nobody
has any questions--
Green: Oh--oh,
we have maybe one.
No, somebody's escaping.
Okay, good.
Oh, no.
You're--Okay, good.
Yes?
man: Um, so, uh, it seems like
a lot of people
in this room are already
in charge
of the accessibility
for their companies.
If you were somebody
who just recognizes
that everyone should be able
to use whatever you write,
what would be a good place
to start
working on accessibility?
Or a good example of
a very accessible website
for all sorts of disabilities.
Green: So a very accessible
website?
Uh, that's a good question.
I mean, generally,
simpler websites
are easier to make accessible.
Um, there's, uh, I don't know.
Charles, do you have an example?
The best example you
could think of?
[Chen speaks indistinctly]
Yeah, that's true.
With ChromeVox,
we have a tutorial.
It's--It is highly accessible.
However, it's not particularly
complex.
What I would do is
I'd direct you--
We've got a tech talk tomorrow
on building accessible
applications with HTML5,
where we'll actually
walk you through
everything you need
to do to build, uh,
dynamic accessible applications.
Um, they've got a rich,
uh, application
that they'll walk you through.
Cool.
Thanks.
Steve?
Jacobs: Thank you, Brad.
Thank you, Erin.
Thanks to the audience.
The question was just asked
about an accessible--
an example of
an accessible website.
Building a business case
is important
if you want to integrate
accessibility
within your company.
I'm a businessman.
I'm in business to make money.
And I'm in business for
applications to be accessible,
usable, and useful
by as many people
around the world as possible.
So for right now,
let's not think about people
with disabilities,
of which there are
826 million worldwide.
Let's just
concentrate on, uh,
people like myself.
65 years of age and over.
519 million.
And 1.2 billion people
who never learned to read.
How are they gonna access
your apps
and go shopping
and spend their money?
That's where accessibility
is powerful.
Gonna show you two examples
of apps
that we recently developed.
The first is, um,
Khan Academy.
I need to turn on TalkBack's
virtual D-pad.
Um, Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit
educational organization
whose mission
is to evolutionize education
as we know it in the country.
Uh, actually, around the world.
They have about
10 million students
taking their tutorials.
They've developed 2,200
short video tutorials
on subjects such as, uh,
history, math, science,
and so on.
Using the built in accessibility
that's already in Android,
if I swipe down the D-pad...
computer: Math, science,
humanity, science, math.
Jacobs: If I want math
and I hear it,
I don't have to be able
to read.
I just tap it.
computer: KhAndroid.
Arithmetic.
The most basic
of the math playlists--
Jacobs: Arithmetic.
computer: Developmental math.
Jacobs: Developmental math.
Arithmetic.
computer: Playlists start here
if you--KhAndroid.
Basic addition.
Addition. 271,000...
Jacobs: Let's go
into addition too.
computer: YouTube image button.
Jacobs: We will now see--
man: We got some practice
adding what we could--
computer: Alert phone option.
Jacobs: Oops.
computer: Screen off.
[overlapping speech]
man: We could imagine that
if maybe I had three lemons.
One, two, three.
And if I were to add
to those three lemons,
maybe two limes.
computer: Navigating.
man: Is it lime or limes?
Let's just--Well--
Two green lemons
for two more tart pieces--
Jacobs: We can turn
captions off.
man: How much tart,
sour fruit do I have now?
computer: Alert captions.
YouTube.
Jacobs: Or turn them on.
We can pause the video.
We can move the video ahead.
And I'm going
pretty quick here.
Orientation.
man: It means I have no lemons.
So 0, 1, 2, 3, 4...
computer: Typing.
man: 5, 6, 7...
computer: Navigating.
man: 8, 9, 10, 11--
computer: Back, back.
Jacobs: Okay.
That's one example.
And I wanted to thank,
uh, Casey Burkhardt.
Google had a Google I/O--
An accessibility
Google I/O contest
where people submitted code.
And, Casey Burkhardt,
you're in the audience.
Hold your hand up.
Thank you.
You submitted code that our
developers were able to use
to develop this application.
Um, sharing code is part
of the DNA of Android
and the Google culture.
It is very, very helpful.
Uh, it reduces costs
significantly,
and when we work together
as a community,
it's a very good thing from
a business standpoint.
The second app...
computer: Clicked.
Jacobs: I'm going
to demonstrate.
computer: Alert.
Please wait.
Jacobs: We've all seen
e-book readers.
There has been
a lot of talk lately
about e-book readers that can't
read out loud or that won't.
This is CoolReader.
We've simply taken
the open source code
and our developers added speech
and highlighting
and extra controls to the app,
all because it's open source and
it's a community of sharing.
This will give you some idea
of the controls that you have
just having a touch screen.
Um, let's...
computer: For a whole day--
Jacobs: read backwards.
Indeed, my only wonder was
that he had not
already been mixed up in--
I was not surprised.
Jacobs: Or we can read one word
at a time.
computer: Word.
Violent.
Kings.
Sentence.
Jacobs: Or go back to sen--
Okay, we're back
to the sentence.
Let's go into night mode.
You can see it better.
We'll go back into day mode.
We can turn a page
or turn it back
or increase the size
of the font.
We can do that again.
Maybe again.
So people who are not
able to read,
who are learning to read,
learning English
as a second language,
Young students who want
to be able
to access resources
like this,
having an interface
that is accessible
can enable them to do that.
It is very, very powerful.
So expand your thinking
about accessibility
beyond disabilities,
if you're narrowly focused
on disabilities.
Couple of other features
and then I'll stop.
Uh, we can go
to the table of contents...
computer: Alert.
Table of contents.
CoolReader.
Jacobs: And turn some pages.
I can dim the screen
if I want to.
I can brighten the screen.
There are 20 commands
built into the touch screen
in 9 little areas.
We actually make
templates that we can put
over as screen savers
that enable the students
who are blind
that we work with
to fully control this
application,
fully control KhAndroid and many
of the other applications
we develop.
Thank you.
Rosenthal: Thanks, Steve.
Jacobs: Welcome.
Rosenthal: Let me switch
back over.
Green: All right.
Steve, that's awesome.
That's wonderful.
So I want to just
kind of reiterate
a couple of the points
about Steve's demo.
On CoolReader,
they were using gestures,
notice, that didn't require
a user to look at the screen.
A user, no matter where they
started from in their gestures,
they always kind of knew
how it would make sense.
Some of them were relative to
different parts of the screen,
but I didn't need
to see the screen.
And then they provided a lot
of verbal feedback to the user.
So the user, again,
could know what was going on
without seeing what was
on the screen.
KhAndroid is a fantastic example
of rethinking, uh--
How do I make it possible
for more users
to use my application by adding
other modes of accessibility?
Um, and we're really proud that
they were able to reuse
some of the code from the
developer challenge that we had.
Rosenthal: So let's talk
a little bit about
making your products accessible
for people who are deaf
or hard of hearing.
Um, as Dr. I. King Jordan said,
"Deaf people can do anything
but hear."
Um, and by the way,
Dr. I. King Jordan
was the first deaf president
of Gallaudet University,
which was the first university
for deaf and hard
of hearing students.
Their entire curriculum is for--
is in ASL.
Um, so, uh, mobile devices
and deaf communities--
Um, sorry.
Uh, mobile devices were rapidly
adopted by the deaf community.
I mean, when you think
about it,
um, deaf people do more than
just, you know--
We do more with our cell phones
than just talk on them, right?
I, you know, increasingly
use my cell phone
less and less for phone calls
and more for other
text-based things
like text chatting and SMS
and now for things
like video chatting
and watching videos, right?
So watching videos
with captions
goes well with that.
We have, um,
Jaehong Chon here
from the University
of Washington
to show us this great
application that they've built
to customize, uh--
So you can go ahead
and plug in.
Chon: Thanks for doing this.
Rosenthal: Wait.
Hold on.
Some of the great technologies
that they've built
to help make a great
video chat experience
for deaf users.
Chon: Okay, um,
it's my great honor
to present our work here.
Rosenthal: Do you want to--
Chon: Yeah, so.
Rosenthal: There we go.
Switch over.
Chon: Yeah.
That's okay.
Just show them after
presenting the slide.
Rosenthal: Yes, oh, right.
We're still on slides.
Sorry.
Chon: Yeah, that's fine.
Rosenthal: There you go.
It's over here.
Chon: Yeah.
Thank you.
Um, basically,
I'm a Ph student at U-Dub
to work on Google
as their project.
It all started
about six years ago,
and then we conduct a vista last
year, like this picture,
uh, using, uh,
the old platform.
So last year, we decided
to move to Android
to give the same access
to Android Word.
But the reason is that basically
there are some--
a system like VRS,
video relay service,
but it requires high-speed,
uh, internet service,
to afford them that access.
So it means they cannot
use the system on the go.
So our goal is to provide
the same access,
um, where they--
wherever they are.
So we built the video chat
for sign language
and then working on the cellular
network as well as the wi-fi.
So the reason choose
the cellular network
is that we can give
that access everywhere.
And then so we
optimize something
to enable the technology.
So we, uh, investigate
to speed up the encoder
to enable--to provide
the video code,
as well as the--
providing low--
low bit rate to be transmitted
over the network.
So I've brought
some video here.
So our target bit rate
is 32 bits per second.
On the left top,
there's the original video.
First of all,
we want it to detect
the skin area.
And then, uh,
give to us too some blocks
to be encoded
with a higher bit rate.
So finally, at the bottom,
there's two different videos.
The right side,
uh,
it used that information
to encode--
to be, um, better quality.
It means the less to build,
it would be to--relative
to meet the same
amount of bit.
And then that bit rate
can be easily transmitted
over [indistinct]
network.
Rosenthal: So were you able
to get the demo to work
or do you want
to show the video?
Chon: Uh, show the video.
Rosenthal: Okay.
Chon: So, actually, uh,
I've asked the people--
We decided to move
to Android Word,
so we built the system
from last year
and then we had the working
system here,
but because of network issue,
it is not working
well perfectly.
So I will show that demo
using the prerecorded video.
I took that video
yesterday night
with the [indistinct] network.
So, uh, seems to be better,
but up here, it's not working.
So please come by
our sandbox booth.
We're gonna show more
information.
Thank you.
Rosenthal: Great.
Thanks, Jaehong.
Chon: Yeah.
Rosenthal: Okay, back to this.
So, um, to summarize,
there are some key things
that you can do
to make your applications
accessible.
One is to just make sure you
understand your users
and the use cases under which
they'll be using your products.
Um, focus on mating--
making products
that enable independence
and have multiple
ways of interacting so that
you don't end up relying
on one method
like using a mouse.
That you have
redundant methods
like using a keyboard.
Um, make sure that
you provide good feedback
in your applications
so that your users
know where they are
at all times.
And also, think of your entire
end-to-end experience
from the moment they log in
or even browse your pro--
Like, to browse your website
to learn about your product,
to the point where
they're setting it up
using the settings and,
uh,
looking up documentation.
Green: That's right.
So just to leave you with
a couple points from the talk.
Our standard toolkits
come with
great accessibility built in.
Use them.
There's a couple things
that, uh--
We want to make sure
the biggest thing
you could do is to make sure
that your application
can be used by
the keyboard alone
if it's a web app,
or can be focused and used
by a trackpad or a roller ball
if it's a mobile application.
Uh, I want to make sure
that I'm handling
tab and focus events properly,
whether I'm in Android
or on the web.
And then test it in
the type of accessibility
technology that
you want to target.
So download ChromeVox and try
your application out.
Um, or use the, uh,
TalkBack
on the Android platform.
Rosenthal: So there's
a number of ways
where you can learn
more about accessibility
while you're here at I/O.
Um, the first one was
unfortunately a session
that was earlier today,
which you're gonna
have to catch on YouTube,
but it was great.
It was a session
on using Android
and making your Android apps
accessible.
Tomorrow--
Uh, tomorrow at 12:30,
we have a session
on YouTube,
captioning API and speech
recognition and WebVTT.
And then from 3:00 to 4:00
tomorrow afternoon,
we have a presentation
on, um,
making accessible web apps
using HTML5.
Then all day
today and tomorrow,
we have a developer sandbox
out here on the second floor.
It's one of the yellow booths,
for those of you who are
photon-dependent.
Um, there's eight different
stations there
and you can get a better sense
of all these applications
and use them yourselves.
Um, the demos will be there.
And then we also have office
hours right now, actually.
Uh, started at 3:00
and going until 6:30 today.
And then tomorrow
from 3:00 to 5:00.
And those are, again,
on the second floor.
If you walk around,
there's three little nooks
and we're in the last one,
um, outside the room at the end.
Green: Great, okay.
So to give us feedback,
we would love
to get your input
on how this talk went.
There's a QR code at the top
or you can just type in
the feedback link.
The links for the other things
we referenced
during the talk,
including how to download,
uh, ChromeVox and ChromeVis--
uh, I'm sorry--
and ChromeShades
are there at the second link.
Thanks, everybody.
Please come up to the mics
if you have other questions.
[applause]